I've used the term weaponized ignorant
and weaponized narcissism before when
talking about Donald Trump these have
never been more relevant terms than
right now with the CV situation we're
calling it the cool virus to avoid D
monetization on YouTube I think you guys
remember CV the US has not been testing
people the US has done as of early this
past weekend only about 1800 total tests
when you have at the time it was 400
cases and you've only done 2000 or 1800
tests you just don't know how prevalent
this is in the general population but
you are certainly dramatically
understating the number of cases this is
Donald Trump's fault the WHL made a test
available which Trump's CDC rejected
they said we're trying to make our own
tests that failed and now we are
embarassingly behind on this issue Trump
went to the CDC in Atlanta people
started asking questions to the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
Alex Azhar and a CDC doctor about the
lack of tests and Trump interrupts and
wildly claims without evidence because
it's a total lie that they have a test
that anyone who wants the test can get
it despite dr. Redfield from the CDC
saying well we have some tests we have a
limited number we've got to get him out
doctors from all over the country saying
we have no tests notice Trump's
attention deficit in full-swing as well
looking around the room as the adults
talk until he decides to interrupt with
his disinformation doctor talk to you
they believe him you won't believe me
let's not continue to send
[Music]
we continued our first our first
responsibility CDC as I said was to
develop the eyes the lab second
responsibility is to get that out to the
public health and we anybody that wants
a test so this is not true we are so far
behind on getting tests done there are
people with presumptive cases not being
tested and sent home we haven't done any
tests in broader communities like South
Korea has done it's a mess now the the
the part we're not that I care about the
politics but that is interesting is that
Trump would benefit politically from
having done way more tests because it is
almost guaranteed that the death rate in
the u.s. is well below the international
death rate which is very heavily skewed
towards China and towards the beginning
of this when it appears you know that a
more chaotic situation led to inferior
treatment if Donald Trump had done a lot
more tests he would be able to say
listen we can trust that we know the
number of cases and our death rate is
really low that would help him
politically he may not even realize that
but it doesn't even matter he's lying
and that's what it what is important
here now in this next clip Trump claims
to have some kind of special ability on
medicine and medical related issues
apparently because his uncle John Trump
taught at MIT
this is weaponized ignorance and weapon
webinars narcissism John Trump was some
super genius so Trump says doctors are
regularly shocked by how much he knows
about medicine imagine what's going on
in this guy's head I've seen what
they've done back there it's really
by the way NIH but they've done I spend
time over there mushrooms at MIT he
taught at MIT for I lived like a record
number of years he's a great super
genius dr. John Trump I like this stuff
I really get it no surprises I
understand every ward of these notches
that have you know so much about this
maybe I have a natural ability the whole
world can you imagine from praising
himself for how much he knows about
medicine claims doctors are impressed
with his medical knowledge meanwhile we
can't even test people for the cool
virus because we have barely any tests
and then here's the icing on the cake of
incompetence when Secretary of Health
and Human Services as our is trying to
explain the truth about the tests Trump
interrupts and says the tests are
beautiful the tests are beautiful thanks
a million tests so they shipped 700
thousand already the remaining lots are
actually being tested here dr. Monroe's
got them as what I think 10:30 this
morning and they have to do the quality
control and then if they pass what but I
think I think anybody right now
and yesterday anybody that needs a task
gets a test me they're there they have
the tests and the tests of you
anybody that needs a test gets a test if
there's a doctor that wants to test if
there's somebody coming off the ship
like the big monster ship that's out
there right now which you know again
that's a big decision I won't bring all
those people on so there it is Trump
says it it's a beautiful test has anyone
ever seen a beautiful virus test what
does that even mean and you just know
Trump is lying and clueless and in way
over his head when he starts calling
tests beautiful when he starts calling
anything beautiful remember he said
we're gonna replace Obamacare with a
beautiful system never happened turned
out the only thing he proposed would
have led to 20 or 30 million more people
losing their health insurance we're in
trouble and I want to talk more about
the testing thing because it's not just
indifference Trump's refusal to use the
World Health Organization test starting
a while ago is actually responsible for
a more quickly growing outbreak than
we'd otherwise have real quick I want to
tell you about a YouTube channel called
up flip they're friends of our show you
can check them out by going to david
pakman.com slash up flip the link is
down below underneath the video every
week up flip publishes a new video where
you get to meet an entrepreneur learn
about the business they built see what
it's like to live a day in their shoes
in that business I love learning about
small business owners the steps they
took to become successful that's why I
love the content on up flip you'll get
an exclusive look at some really
fascinating businesses each entrepreneur
has many valuable insights and
strategies to share about how to build
and maintain a successful company I
would highly recommend their two-part
series on lean manufacturing which
itself is a really interesting concept
that's all about sort of minimizing
waste maximizing efficiency and up flip
breaks it all down you can get to their
channel by going to david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is right below
this video make sure you subscribe to
their channel and click that Bell icon
so you'll be notified when they upload
new videos